en 2013 cette eau énergie musicaux hélas
oui mon sang n'a fait qu'un tour
je vais vous dire il a tourné très vite
j'ai été en prise de sang je pense que
vous aussi
tu te rappelles mais l'art la robe de
franck sorbier
oui le galoche la guerre n'est pas une
galoche
alors c'est au moulante une robe longue
à la galoche et la robe était différent
à ses deux chats temps c'est franchement
peut-être moi je suis grave kiffé non
mais je trouve ces voix là c'est du
chocolat chaud même sort que toi qu'a
fait jean pierre je te jure que c'est
vrai surtout qu'ils sont des répète on
ne l'a pas fait pour et non sur en
direct on l'a fait sur un clip avec bg
dream n'est pas faux répète et a bien
fait calloc'h de ouf dans le clip
rappelle les frais regardez regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si j'ose les le pas
thomas a
cinquante a eu l'idée avec c'était une
banque on était en plein débat pour le
mariage pour tous homosexuels exactement
h pour tous et voilà on sait d'où le
doubs le décor le concept du gâteau et
de l'arc-en-ciel et de commencer ce
mariage avec mon danseur jonathan
genvrin qui est gay et qu'on a mis on a
couvert d'une d'un voile et il arrivait
justement à la fin avec cette peine
galoche un petit business j'aime bien ce
mac est ce qu'on appelle un nom mais ça
et ça c'est quoi le smac améliorer ça
dans le milieu vous l'aurez reconnue
bien entendu c'est ça on va finir pas
souvenir mon haleine mais avec la crise
oblige h et passe à l'achat qu'à
l'habitude non mais t'es europe tout
faux pas ben non j'ai pas eu rope
j'étais tellement dans l'excitation on
était au lendemain des attentats
on était on était peu dans la salle et
avait tellement un autre mot ou un truc
un peu particulier c'était assez pesant
ayant abandonné ou ceux ceux-là je
l'avais fait dix mille fois avant mais
je prévenais les gens etc et l'âge était
survoltée donc j'ai pas prévenus et il
ya une réception de bath à tardi je n'ai
pas touché le sol mais de l'extérieur on
a l'impression
voilà c'est un slameur athée regarder
mais ça va mieux alors c'est bon oui
c'est bon t'as plus rien et tu passe me
voir au cabinet jo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça rend pas compte mais la distance
pierre entre la scène et l'autre à
l'arrière et les ombres vous savez
j'avais pas j'avais pas évaluer les
distances et alors après le plus
plusieurs c'était leur faire de l'europe
un le lendemain lorsque j'ai un j'ai un
petit ego quand même et j'ai voulu leur
faire j'aime aussi le lendemain quand
elle voit là franchement tout cas shy'm
fait tout ce que tu fais tu es la seule
à faire en france je trouve des
exceptions accroît les voir en tournée